on the bound for the padres today is you
darvish
second start of the season versus these
d-backs the 34-year-old making his 16th
start overall in really
all-star numbers as you look at this
ledger here 189 opponents banning
average
it's wind day when you darvish is on the
hill obviously the era great the
strikeouts are great
picked up his 1500th career strikeout in
his last start on monday against the
dodgers
swing and a miss and darbish gets his
first k of the day
he knows exactly what the padres are up
against and uh he's one of those guys
that's going to tell himself you know
what i want to go seven or eight innings
1 500 and one career strikeouts now
for you garvish so one down and it
brings up pavin smith who gets a start
in center field
on the outside corner for strike three
back-to-back strikeouts to start the day
for you darvish
i think payment smith had that breaking
ball down and into the back of his mind
because there's the fastball running on
the outside corner at 96.
well if you're looking in and you get
that good luck
that is strike three a one two three
first with three strikeouts for you
darvish continuing his comeback after he
missed six weeks with a ucl spring in
his right elbow
very impressive last time out against
the brewers yeah really had it all
working last time out against the
brewers and more than anything else just
his uh his
mental approach he really maybe it was
the lead off home run by colton long
that got him into where he needed to be
but really focused really attacking that
strike zone the rest of the day against
the brewers
tommy pham had a lead-off home run the
other night he'll lead this one off
drives one to center field payment smith
is back at the wall it's gone
tommy fam is fantastic and the padres
off to the fast start
a leadoff home run that'll do another
lead-off home run for tommy fam
unbelievable that is his fourth of the
season
and the padres seventh one to nothing
san diego in the first
talk about a guy with ultimate
confidence tommy pham is that guy
and fast starts off to leeds with the
exception of last night there's a liner
the other way
for trump gershom into the left field
corner grisham headed for second base
he's got a double
good start for the padres today grisham
at second base nobody out here in the
first inning jake coroner standing in
on the ground up the middle that'll find
its way into center field
here comes grisham around to score and
the padres take a two-nothing lead
did not have a complete opposite inning
compared to the d-backs three punch-outs
for the d-backs their first three
hitters
padres three hits the kid is
a battler down 0-2 works at 2-2
missed location corona worth on first
nobody out fernando tatis junior at the
plate
and the pitch and tantis when he's down
on strikes
well gallant set him up on that previous
pitch
what a way and tantis with a
half-hearted swing strikes out one away
gallon ready there goes the runner and
myers hits one down to short ahmed's got
it nick throws to first to get myers
that'll end the inning padres get two on
three hits in the ending the home run by
fam
harveyick hit by cronenworth and we
played one in san diego
reddick rifles one to right myers plays
and it gets to the wall
he knocked it down anyway and redicks at
second base with two outs
that's a double for josh his tenth this
year
oh two swinging a miss ran the cutter in
on varsha he had no chance
and a strikeout to end the second fourth
of the day already for you darvish
with two down the third base is empty
and the padres out to a two-nothing lead
and in those runs in the first van meter
waiting in the left-hand batter's box
darvish is set he kicks and deals
and the 3-2 pitch is on the outside
corner strike three
called a perfect back-up slider and now
six strikeouts in three shutout innings
for you darvish first and second with
one out here in the padres third inning
it's jammed and pops it up first base
way christian walker
into foul ground makes the catch able to
get fernando and that'll bring up eric
cosmer
and the pitch from gallant and a ground
ball left side
ahmed's got it has to go to first for
the out i think he was wanting to throw
to van meter
and uh either he wasn't there felt
better going to first base
hosmer was about halfway down the line
so first and third
of a place situation still for the
padres
that kicks away from carrottini and
pavett is home
diamondbacks have their first run they
called it a cutter
he just really spiked that well out in
front of home plate that time
sharply hit it's a one hopper tatis to
second for one on to first
just in time padres turn it on here's
ahmed
on one and one ahmed a hit into the left
field corner extra bases
fam has to track it down and nick's into
sega base standing
with a one out double off darvish it's
five hits off darvish yeah it's a nice
series nick's having here in san diego
crowd trying to get behind you darvish
and help him through this
fifth inning two balls and his strike to
pavon smith
here it is from darvish swinging a line
drive into center grisham came in now he
drifts back
over the shoulder he makes the catch
down the inning no runs a hit and the
diamondbacks
leave two in the top of the fifth big
opportunity here for the padres with
two outs in the fifth inning now buchter
trying to get out of trouble here
and then there's city without a run
scoring ball ripped or right
but right at reddick for the out medal
in the anybody he hit an armband out
and the diamondbacks escape without a
run scoring for san diego
one and two here it is to josh redick
kind of golfs it out towards shallow
left fam charging in
towards the line he gets underneath of
it reaches up to make the catch
and the side is retired cabrera the lead
single
on the bunt against the shift but he
goes no further than first base we've
played five and a half innings base has
loaded nobody out here for the d-backs
they've been threatening last couple of
innings and now
big spot in the game eduardo chops at
the first one
matisse throws it away marshall is home
to tie the ball game here comes ahmed
and the diamondbacks have the lead
fernando tatis jr a lot of defensive
errors early in the season
that was a double play ball that really
would have helped san diego and he threw
it into right field
now the batter will be cabrera he'll be
right-handed
high in the air meyers in right
rojas at third and here he comes
rbi fours drooble make it a 4-2 d-backs
lead
pro far at third base fam at first with
nobody out in the seventh
and trent christian swings here shoots
it out towards deep left center field
smith on the run going over can't get
there
he'll cut it off profile will come in to
score grisham in his second
his third double of the day it's a
one-run game in the bottom of the
seventh inning
second and third nobody out of run-in
and you got jake cronenworth coming up
here for san diego
lions one to center field that's it for
a hit
from third comes fam
and christian will have to stay at third
pham didn't run
for some reason i guess he thought that
smith was going to make the play out
there in center so he stayed at third
base
and really running up from behind him
was grisham he almost
ran by him and had to stop at third base
so the padres only get one run out of
that
four hits in a row nobody out and
runners at the corners
chop down the left field wide four ball
from third comes grisham
heading two third is cronoworth to
second with an rbi double
goes fernando padres had the lead back
again
the top twist one-two count on hassan
kim
peacock's pitch and a swing and a miss
he strike him out
so peacock strikes out three hitters
with runners at second and third
this is where the friar faithful
everybody at petco park
all 34 905. get up on your feet
hey struck him out in the padres win a
one two three ninth inning for mark
malanson
and the padres hold on to win it five to
four they take
9 out of 10 on the home stand what a
home stand it was